كاس العالم في مصر سيكونوا مختلفا هذا
العام غياب محمد صلاح وتاثيره على متابعه
المصريين للبطوله لن يمنعهم من الجدل حول
احداثه لكن الفنيه منها خصوصا مع مشاركه
مؤديل مهرجانات حسن شاكوش في فعاليات
الغناء الموندياليه الجدل القائم يعود الى
الصوره التي يرى فيها العالم فن مصر مع
انتشار المهرجانات الشعبيه عالميا الامر
الذي يجده البعض تشويها للفن المصري
الاصيل لا تتوقف المقارنه هناك بين الماضي
الجميل والحاضر الغريب المعتمد على عناصر
قد يراها البعض غريبه المزيد معنا دجاج من
القاهره
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
نصر وحاضره في مونديال قطر ليس بمحمد صلاح
والمنتخب المصري بطبيعه الحال بل بحسن
شاكوش مؤدي لمهرجانات الشعبيه الشهير الذي
كشف مؤخرا عن مشاركته في الفعاليات الفنيه
بالعرس الرياضي العالمي الذي سيبدا بعد
ايام النجم المصري والشعبي فرح بالمشاركه
ولا يابا بالاصوات المعارضه له او لنوع
اغنيته التي ربما يجدها البعض غير مناسبه
لتمثيل مصر لكنه ربما يستقوي بالفيفا الذي
اعلن عن كوني ما يقدمه شاكوش يمثل جزءا
كبيرا من الحياه في العالم العربي يحزن
جمع كبير من المصريين على عدم حضور
المنتخب المصري في كاس العالم ولكن بعضهم
يفرح بحضوره فن جديد اصبح كما يرون
من الهويه التعريفيه بهم خارجه بلادهم
ويرون ايضا انه لا يمكن اليوم انكار ان
المهرجانات رغم كل الانتقادات لمواجهه
اليها صارت اداه للتعبير المصري البسيط
وعلى راي المثل لولا اختلاف الاذواق لبارت
السلعه ولا على الاختلاف في الذوق العام
يجعل من المهرجانات التي يبغضها البعض
الاخر فلن حاضرا في اكبر تجمع رياضي عالمي
سيرقص عليها كثيرون وربما سيتعرفون على
شاكوش وما يؤديه للمرات الاولى لصباح
العربيه ندى حجازي القاهره
اموره وكيوته وكيوته
مع هذا الجدل نذهب الى ضيوف صباح العربيه
في فقره معوض ضدنا القاهره ينضم الينا
الناقد الموسيقي محمد شميس هو الناقد
الفني مصطفى الكيلاني مرحبا بكما معنا في
صباح العربيه محمد ابدا معك بالعاده حدث
ضخم مثل كاس العالم يتم باستعانه بفنانين
عالميين معروفين عربيا ودوليا وايضا
فنانين عرب معروفين عربيا وايضا دوليا لكن
ان يتم الاستعانه بمؤدي مهرجانات اليس فيه
نوع من المبالغه ولا منطقيه ما رايك
لا هو بس في خلط احنا محتاجين نفسر ونقس
الموضوع وحفل افتتاح كاس العالم حاجه
والمهرجان الجماهيري اللي عاملاه فيفا
للجماهير المشاركه في كاس العالم حاجه
ثانيه في حفل الافتتاح ده حتى هذه اللحظه
لم يعلن من هو هيبقى مسؤول عن الفقرات
الفنيه فيه وفيه البوم غنائي برده دي حاجه
ثالثه بتعملي
حدث ضخم كبير
تمام وهو الموضوع حسن شاكوش برده لازم
نفهم الاختيار جاي على اساس ايه لان هو كل
المجاميع المشاركه معه من الفنانين في
المهرجان ده بيحاولوا يخلقوا حاله من
التنوع وكل الاغاني او كل المغنيين او
الصناع الموسيقى اللي هيبقوا موجودين
بيقدموا نوع من الغنى التلقائي الشعبي لان
هم في الاول اخر بيخاطبوا جماهير كره
القدم همم يعني بالتحديد اكثر بالاغاني
اللي خارجه من مناطق همم ذات كثافه
جماهيريه كبيره وده كله طبعا العناصر دي
متوفره كلها في حسن شاكوش مش موضوع افضليه
يعني ان في مغني
خلينا نسمع وجهه نظر مصطفى بهذا الخصوص
مصطفى اليوم بيقولوا لك انه مشاركه حسن
شاكوش مش بافتتاحيه كاس العالم بل
بفعاليات كاس العالم بشكل عام فما المانع
اذا
هو في في مشكله اصلا هو انه انه بقى في
همم مسارات كتير ومؤسسات كتير بقت بتدعم
ما يسميه فن الرداءه همم انا مع انه يبقى
في غنى عشوائي لمساحه معينه همم يتطور بعد
كده انه يبقى له مكان بعد ما يتطور لكن ان
احنا ندعم فن الرداء ده ويفضل
هذا يعني انت انت تطلق عليه هذا اللقب نحن
لا نتمنى هذا اللقب لكن هذا الفن لديه
جمهور كبير جدا
اوكي هو لديه جمهور ما هو احنا النهارده
حضرتك انت بتلاقي على على منصات السوشيال
ميديا ال- ال- الاقوى والاكثر تاثيرا هو
الحاجات التافهه جدا والحاجات المسيئه جدا
جدا والحاجات اللي مش طبيعيه اصلا لانه في
الاخر السوشيال ميديا بتخلق العالم ده
وبتروج ليه بالناسبه وخاصه في منطقتنا
احنا النهارده بيتم ترويج بشكل متعمد له
ده همم انا انا مش ضده لكن برده مش معه
همم ده له مكانه وليه وليه مساحته لكن ان
يكون في في في حاجه زي كاس العالم ممثله
للفن المصري دي صعب قوي يعني يعني ما
اقدرش ما اقدرش
بصراحه يا مصطفى
اه طبعا
اللي بتقول عنه الفن الرديئه
لا لا اعرفهم اعرفهم بس في الاخر مش
بردتهم
اعرفهم لكن لكن
الفرق كبير بيننا من خلال موجود في الحياه
في مصر موجود محضر افراح وبحضر حفلات
وبشوف المجتمع اللي حواليا بيتاثر بايه ده
طبيعي جدا جدا كمان حتى الحكم عملي
كصحفي مهتم بالفن بالاساس اوكي لكن ان انا
اكون متابع حاجه او باسمع بالصدفه حاجه
وانه ده اهتماماتي حاجه ثانيه لا تفرق
كتير
انا مختلف طبعا مع كل المصطفى بيقولوا
جمله كان تفصيله لان اول حاجه لكل حاجه
حاجه احنا دلوقتي عايزين بنعمل مهرجان
جماهيري خاص بعشاق كره القدم فاحنا
محتاجين الناس اللي عندهم الاغاني
الحماسيه والاغاني الايقاعيه اللي بترقص
الناس ومش محتاجه ان هي تبقى يعني بعيد عن
ودانهم فاحنا بنجيب واحد خارج من قلب
الشارع المصري بدا في الافراح الشعبيه
وصم- فضلت تطور احنا بنتكلم على اكبر
المهرجانات مثلا الغنائيه الجماهيريه مثلا
زي مهرجان موسم الرياض حسن شاكوش بيبقى
موجود هناك في افتتاح بطوله عربيه حسن
شاكوش برده موجود وشفنا العرب كلهم مش
باتكلم عن المصريين ازاي لما الراجل ده
كان بيغني الناس وقفت في المدرجات وبدات
ترقص وتتفاعل مع الغنى بتاعه وكمان هو
ملمس مع كره القدم لانه كان لاعب كره سابق
في نادي الاسود في نادي الاسماعيلي المصري
فالراجل برده متتاسس على فكره التعبير مع
جمهوره ازاي يتحد معه وزاي يعرف يعبر عنه
الحاجات دي في الاطار اللي حطاه الفيفا مش
هينفع طبعا يعني همم خلينا نتخيل كده نجيب
مثلا مغني اوبرالي مصري يقف في شحاته
جماهيريه شعبيه اللي ناس جايين من مختلف
بلدان العالم علشان خاطر تستمتع بكوره
القدم ده مكانه مثلا في الاوبرا يعني وهو
حسن شاكوش طبعا فن مصري بنسبه 100% بالعكس
اغلب اغانيهم بس الموضوع مهم جدا ده يعني
اي احد في العالم يسمعه واغاني حسن شاكوش
100% يقول ده مصري من غير ما يسمع من اول
ما المزيكا تشتغل ده ما بيعرفش يعمله اصلا
كبار الصناعه موسيقى البوب اغلبهم يعني
والله هم واحد ولا اثنين طيب مصطفى محمد
عم بيقول انه اغاني حسن شاكوش اغاني
حماسيه تتناسب مع هذا الحدث حدث رياضي
يجامع كل العالم ونحن بنعرف انه مصر بلد
كبير جدا ويمثل جزء كبير من العالم العربي
بالتالي يعني الاستعانه بفنان مثل حسن
شاكوش واغانيه احسن اختيار كيف بترد بتعلق
في اختيارات كثير جدا
مطرب اوبرالي ولا حتى مثلا على الحجار ولا
مدحت صالح فيه موجودين همم ناس من نجوم
الباب زي ما هو قال همم شميز انه انه همم
في ناس كثير مهمه في عمرو دياب في حماقي
وفي وفي همم لو احنا عايزين اغاني حماسيه
ممكن نجيب فرقه سعيد الارتست بالطبله تجنن
ال- ال- الجمهور كلها انه همم حسن شاكوش
اه بيعبر عن همم
العشوائيات انا باسميه
ده ده ده ده اللي موجود وده للاسف اللي
بيمثل النتاج سنين من فقدان الهويه
المصريه لكن احنا النهارده
احنا عندنا حاجات كثير جدا وعندنا همم
مطربين يقدروا يعملوا حاجات حماسيه اكثر
من حسن شاكوش بكثير جدا طيب محمد ما بتعرف
انه حسن شاكوش استغل نوعا ما فكره ترويجه
للغناء في كاس العالم يعني تركها مفتوحه
لم يخصص انه اليوم المحدد او اليوم
الفلاني قال انه يعلن مشاركته في كاس
العالم
تحمله الصحافه الفنيه للاسف اللي بتمر
بازمه شديده جدا ان ما حدش بيحاول يذاكر
او يشوف مثلا الراجل ده بيقول مثلا
تصريحات فهي الاصل بتاعها هيخش على الموقع
مثلا بتاع الفيفا يشوف لكن طبعا حسن شاكوش
من حقه بالعكس لازم يبقى مبسوط جدا لان
اخيرا في احد بي- جهه رسميه كبيره جدا
بتعترف بشكل فني هو الراجل محقق ده على
القاعده الجماهيريه بيحققه على همم
مشاهدات يوتيوب محققه في تردد في الشارع
في في الاغاني اللي بنسمعها حتى في
العربيات واحنا ماشيين بنسمعه دائما شغال
ف- همم من حقه طبعا ان هو يسخر لان ما فيش
حتى احنا عندنا حاله نقديه دائما متعاليه
همم بتمارس الحكم همم يعني وصايه على
الغيب بتقول للناس انتم المفروض تغنوا زي
المفروض تعملوا ايه حتى بالممارس الوصايه
على اختياراتهم انتم المفروض تختاروا مين
او ما تختاروش مين ما فيش عندنا الحاله
للتحليل او احد يقول اسباب ده ايه لكن
اسباب وهي متمشيه جدا مع الفرق اللي
موجوده كمان بتشارك معه في الفيفا ما هواش
افضل ناس او هم احسن ناس موجودين في
البلاد بتوعهم لكنهم اكثر ناس متواصلين مع
الجمهور بشكل حقيقي كنا معكم بفقره مع وضد
من القاهره ناقد الموسيقي محمد شميس
والناقد الفني مصطفى الكيلاني شكرا لكم